Alice:是不是该换水了
Katrina:  呜呜呜哎
Katrina:  昨天昨天新换的
Katrina:  嗯afterlike好有意思行了出道了
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha:  哒哒哒哒
Katrina:  张元英的团
Tasha:  是的
Katrina:  这有点难
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 啊这个有点难
Tasha:  挑战张元英转圈舞那个
Katrina:  哈
Jake: 哈哈哈可以
Tasha:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  这是真爱豆啊
Katrina:  看张元英的
Lucia: 两天都经常跳
Lucia: 很有力量才
Lucia: 能跳出它这个效果来
Lucia: 我觉得我们这几天可能排不了
Katrina:  呜啊啊
Jake: 嗯
Tasha:  哈这要跳给谁看呢最终
Jake: 得从健身开始
Lucia: 嗯呃我们
Jake: 呃呃呃
Katrina:  那也是OK吧
Jake: 相机哎
Lucia: 可我们还不是有什么九到正无穷
Katrina:  虫子
Jake: 呵呵呵对
Jake: 九到正无穷
Tasha:  啊这么可怕
Jake: 14亿全国人民
Jake: 呵呵呵呵不
Alice: 能不能是全球人民
Jake: 七十亿全球人民
Jake: 对对
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: 七十亿全球人民呵
Katrina:  我手机呢
Katrina:  帮我拿下手机薇薇
Alice: 这个吗
Tasha:  看那个台舞吧
Alice: 塔莎你在吗
Tasha:  yes you see you say
Jake: 像这个领域大概有有100个组
Jake: 100个组在做
Jake: 如果他们都用你们的这个数据的话
Tasha:  什么东西
Jake: 就至少是100个研究员
Jake: 他们要看你们跳舞
Jake: 对呵呵呵呵呵对
Lucia: 但是不是会不是会处理一下
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: 对对对但是是但是你们就会跳舞吗
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 啊
Jake: 对没事
Lucia: 没事他不知道是我就行
Jake: 是是没问题
Lucia: 不知道是我就是
Lucia: 其实我拍难度高的也无所谓
Lucia: 就算跳砸了他也不知道是咱是吗
Katrina:  lady Candle呀
Jake: 对
Alice: 简直不敢相信我要是跳这个舞
Alice: 会有多扭曲
Tasha:  我靠
Alice: 哈哈哈疯了吧
Tasha:  疯了吧
Katrina: 其实我跟你说
Katrina: 张元英他们团的舞你看着简单
Katrina: 好像没什么用力
Katrina: 但是你跳出来很丑
Katrina: 你跳不出张元英那种感觉好
Katrina: 就他们团的舞
Katrina:  我经常不知道怎么发力就很神奇
Tasha:  那yes OK
Tasha:  确实很简单啊
Alice: 来我家玩吧
Alice: 邀请你
Tasha:  看能不能抢到医院的票
Tasha:  我可能五一就要跟我妈妈在北京看病
Tasha:  life
Alice: life
Katrina:  哎我发大群里吧
Lucia: 哎可以剧组会跟我们一起跳吗
Jake: 对你可以跳可以跳
Alice: 剧组是不是就最后一天会来
Jake: 呃也不是周五吧
Lucia: 他们中间还会啊OK
Jake: 周五他们上课啊
Alice: 今天周几周三
Jake: 今天就会来两个
Jake: 上课打卡
Jake: 呃就是紫藤唯一的女生她要打卡
Jake: 他们实验室要打卡
Jake: 所以不太方便来
Jake: 周末可以来
Jake: 周五周六周日
Katrina:  奔跑的青春要分享吗
Lucia: 要不分享一下让大家看看哪个好
Lucia: 不过奔跑吧青春在这几个里面算比较难的一个
Jake: 放到管家群
Jake: 管家一起跳就给你们开小车的
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: 欢迎
Jake: 你们都坐过了吗
Jake: 都做过了
Alice: 我没
Jake: 你还没有做哦
Jake: 今天给你
Jake: 今天还有一次
Alice: 但我没快递
Jake: 没关系今天该兜风了嘛
Katrina: 今天 该买嗯
Lucia: 我们如果要买东西的话得今天最晚明天得买要不然送不到
Jake: 对是的
Katrina:  OK这4个挑吧
Lucia: 我都可以P人的快乐时刻就是让他用帮忙决定的
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  投票吧
Lucia: 而且因为我这几年就是我我
Lucia: 我前两年就开始
Lucia: 跳这种
Jake: 哦对就是这个
Lucia: 这个是我们一个编舞
Jake: 这个没有办法一起挑
Lucia: 对
Katrina:  什么风格
Jake: 对嗯
Katrina:  给我看看
Lucia: 就是这个是前前年的一个就是编舞
Katrina:  啊我就说你有这方
Katrina:  感觉你很有这个气质
Lucia: 对然后我之前学了一段时间hi-pop
Lucia: 但这几年都没怎么跳了
Katrina:  我一般跳爵士比较多
Katrina:  这有点偏民族现代
Lucia: 对对可能更现代舞一点
Lucia: 因为我是没做过民族这个课
Lucia: 我们当时是教现代舞
Lucia: 然后所以就我直接躺下去
Lucia: 就是老师说你们要用到快点学了之后
Katrina:  嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: 然后我就躺下
Katrina:  你这好有气质
Katrina:  这个这个
Katrina:  我有点跳不来
Katrina:  因为我感觉我没那么柔
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: 而且这个也不适合咱们这个场地
Lucia: 其实是我
Katrina:  我们学校办金秋舞蹈时候
Katrina:  就全部都跳这种舞
Alice: 可以坐我旁边吗
Lucia: 啊
Katrina:  跳那种讲历史的那种舞
Alice: 喜欢跟你在一块
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈哈可以可以
Lucia: 其实我乱编的
Lucia: 我们老师让每个每个同学定
Katrina:  你哦你自己编的
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 我们老师让每个同学自己选一个音乐
Lucia: 然后编一段
Lucia: 然后但其实我只编了前一分半
Lucia: 所以后一分半我就胡乱舞蹈哈哈
Alice: 后一分半我知道
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  心理素质好强啊
Lucia: 哈就有点有点PPT卡拉OK那个意思
Katrina:  居然能当人的面糊了
Lucia: 后面我就开始随意发挥
Jake: 哦
Lucia: 把前面的东西再跳一遍
Jake: 可以freestyle
Alice: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 反正没有人知道他原本是什么样的
Katrina:  看一下如果这个只有1分多
Alice: 这个舞我来跳
Alice: 不知道有多丑陋哈哈哈
Katrina:  其他的就是视频了
Lucia: 我前面疫情的时候就是回国
Lucia: 然后不是有一段时间就刚好
Jake: 嗯
Lucia: 马上就是就要结束了
Lucia: 但是就是还没有
Lucia: 那个当时
Lucia: 还没有就是
Jake: 还没解封
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 所以就是我当时被相当于封在上海
Lucia: 去不了别的地方一段时间
Lucia: 然后这段时间在上海找了一个舞室
Lucia: 然后就是那会是吧
Jake: 是是在一个小区还是
Lucia: 本来本来想学一下
Jake: 不是小区不能出
Lucia: 是小区就是他
Lucia: 是舞房的话
Lucia: 一般他都购物中心里面
Jake: 哦这样子OK
Lucia: 然后就是我
Lucia: 我本来想去试一下学那个
Lucia: 我当时报了一个splash
Jake: 哎呀你这也没电了
Lucia: 然后跳了两三节之后我发现不行
Lucia: 我跳不动
Katrina:  嗯
Lucia: 然后我就放弃了
Katrina:  我们我报的那个hip Hop班
Katrina:  我是报通卡
Katrina:  就是什么班都能跳
Katrina:  然后他这黑怕
Katrina:  他是基本不教那种片段舞
Jake: 你这个是没电了
Katrina:  就是只练基本功
Lucia: 那那很好
Katrina:  对有一点点但是会有一点点枯燥
Katrina:  然后像爵士这种
Alice: 你的线呢宝
Lucia: 我没学过爵士
Jake: 没电了就是单纯的没电插上
Lucia: 虽然我觉得很好看
Lucia: 但是我感觉我自己好像不是很能跳出那个感觉就是hi-pop比较适合我
Katrina:  但是你你学这种还挺
Katrina:  其实还挺顺的因为我觉得它还挺柔的
Jake: 没有你要setup一下
Lucia: 真的吗谢谢
Jake: 哦yes好
Lucia: 啊这真的好好看
Katrina:  对
Tasha: blue 蓝牙连接失败
Jake: 好
Jake: 好好
Alice: 看个什么玩吧
Alice: 你也无聊可以跟我分享一下吗
Lucia: 长沙工资比苏州低
Katrina:  就我一个同学找工作呢
Katrina:  他他一个offer在长沙一个在苏州
Katrina:  他在纠结去哪
Jake: 消费也不一样
Alice: 妈呀看不懂
Katrina:  对苏州那是要比长沙
Lucia: 对租房什么的这些
Katrina:  他你知道他今年考研
Katrina:  他他出了分数以后
Alice: 这么多人都在看
Katrina:  他觉得自己稳考不上你知道吗
Katrina:  结果
Katrina:  今年同济的分数比去年低了三四十分
Lucia: 然后他考上了
Katrina:  他其实考上了
Katrina:  但是他没有准备一点的复试
Katrina:  他直接找工作去了
Katrina:  我靠今年真的很奇怪
Jake: 那他后来准备了吗
Katrina:  没准备复试
Katrina:  他直接没去复试他就找工作去了
Lucia: 啊那有点可惜
Katrina:  有点烦
Lucia: 他应该就是
Lucia: 反正已经拿到复试机会了
Jake: 对啊准备个一天吗
Lucia: 就去卡拉OK一下
Katrina:  但是但是他他出那个对好像同济
Jake: 对啊是哈哈哈
Lucia: 说不定就是我了
Jake: 对啊卡拉OK
Jake: 对一会修硕就卡拉OK回来了
Katrina:  还同济还不怎么筛人呢
Lucia: 咳
Jake: 哈哈重新开了
Tasha: 我重新开了要读秒吗
Jake: 要要
Alice: 我们今天是不是还没读秒
Jake: 对
Katrina:  哦还有分花写名字
Katrina:  特别是这种有花苞的可以记录一下
Jake: 来
Jake: 看时间
Katrina:  看游戏吗看比赛吗
Katrina:  我有个舍友天天看
Tasha:  真的吗
Katrina:  对他
Katrina:  他会因为那些选手没打好而气得半死
Tasha:  是的
Katrina:  这这他在宿舍又哭又笑的
Katrina:  看总决赛的时候他看的
Tasha:  哦他看的难道是LCK决赛
Jake: 啊哈这么带劲
Katrina:  难道是他就看英雄联盟
Tasha:  还是LPL吗
Katrina:  我不知道
Katrina:  他看好多
Katrina:  对LPL他他都看
Alice: 你最喜欢谁啊
Tasha:  我最喜欢的就是这支队伍的这个选手
Alice: 这叫啥
Tasha:  他叫Cherry
Katrina:  他看他喜欢
Katrina:  那叫什么小花生
Katrina:  韩国的那个
Tasha:  enough
Katrina:  他叫他对对对
Katrina:  好像是他
Tasha:  哈哈哈我知道
Katrina:  就是那个单眼皮那个他
Tasha:  特别帅的打野
Katrina:  他就说他长得挺帅的
Tasha:  Tina和我喜欢的Chovy
Tasha:  昨去年是一支队伍的
Tasha:  然后今年他们全部都转队了
Lucia: 观赏一下
Alice: 我好像看到过很多次这个名字
Tasha:  Faker
Alice: 嗯看什么顶级的
Katrina:  啊我也是
Katrina:  Faker不是那个最有名的
Tasha:  他就是嗯
Alice: 顶级打野吗
Tasha:  顶级中单
Tasha:  他怎么说呢
Alice: 顶级中单
Tasha:  他特别厉害
Tasha:  怎么说他现在就是已经30岁了
Tasha:  一般选手在25岁就要退役了
Tasha:  就是因为反应速度跟不上
Alice: 嗯
Tasha:  然后他在30岁这年
Tasha:  还拿了一个世界总冠军
Tasha:  哇哦对
Lucia: 喔哦
Tasha:  然后他人身上已经拿过三次冠军
Tasha:  这是第四次冠军
Tasha:  很多人打了十年都没有过一次冠军
Tasha:  对而且他是出道级巅峰吧
Lucia: 好厉害
Tasha:  好像是15岁
Tasha:  然后高中
Tasha:  上初中还是上高中
Tasha:  的时候偶然间被发现了
Tasha:  然后就然后就被选中了
Tasha:  然后就打比赛
Tasha:  然后一打比赛
Tasha:  就把当时的顶级中单
Tasha:  给一对一的杀掉了
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Tasha:  然后就一战成名
Jake: 好过分啊
Jake: 哈哈哈对
Tasha:  对
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Jake: 强盗过分
Jake: 就是就是
Tasha:  就是一出道就强到过分
Tasha:  并且一直强了这么多年
Jake: 对
Katrina:  昨天那个写名字的
Tasha:  而且他就是从来不买皮肤
Tasha:  就是不提倡大家买皮肤
Tasha:  所以他在比赛还是平时的打
Tasha:  打游戏就只用原皮
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈好有意思
Tasha:  哈哈
Katrina:  我纯技术虐
Tasha:  啊对
Tasha:  好像说韩国90%的人只要玩英雄联盟
Tasha:  都是他的粉丝
Jake: 剩下10%嫉妒他是吗呵
Tasha:  男粉啊什么男生嫉妒他
Tasha:  女生都很喜欢他
Tasha:  而且保持着极高的职业素养
Tasha:  到现在都没有谈过一场恋爱
Tasha:  哇为就是为游戏奉献人生的感觉
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: 可以可以好厉害啊
Tasha:  就
Tasha:  尽管他们这支队伍现在就是比较差
Tasha:  之前一段时间Faker他因为手受伤
Tasha:  他就暂时没有参加比赛
Tasha:  然后他们队连最弱的队伍都没有打过
Tasha:  就是十连败
Alice: 哈哈十连败
Tasha:  哈哈哈然后现在飞快
Tasha:  一上场就直接打总
Lucia: carry全场
Tasha:  就直接打总决赛了都
Tasha:  他可能是队伍的一个核心大脑
Tasha:  就那种偏指挥的
Tasha:  还有偏运营的都归他啊
Alice: 他长哪个样子
Tasha:  这是他们队的ad
Tasha:  因为现在在选ad位
Tasha:  这个人长得是不是有点像杨戬
Tasha:  哈哈哈我当时看的时候
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina:  你写一下名字
Tasha:  就是那个宝莲灯里面的那个三眼狼
Katrina:  这选花吗
Alice: 我给你写吧还是你写
Alice: ok这是我
Alice: 给你写啥
Tasha:  给我画个翅膀就行
Alice: 天呐我的翅膀多丑
Tasha:  那个peanut
Alice: 没关系
Tasha:  给你们看看LCK美男
Katrina:  要给他们晒太
Alice: 完了
Alice: 啊怎么办
Katrina:  们稍微挑一下
Alice: 怎么办哈哈哈
Tasha:  就这样吧
Lucia: 哎挺可爱的
Tasha:  这个就是peanut
Alice: 给你加个爱心好了
Tasha:  就是那个小花生
Katrina:  看看我看看是不是他
Katrina:  抖音经常发的那个男人
Tasha:  啊哈哈
Katrina:  是他我知道
Tasha:  我知道
Tasha:  很帅啦
Katrina:  我给你看他的抖音
Katrina:  他每天都发这些的
Lucia: 确实很帅啊
Tasha:  真的很帅的
Lucia: 确实挺帅的
Katrina:  他是是挺帅的
Tasha:  嗯是呃
Tasha:  这种辅助型打野的代表了啊
Tasha:  这个就是我喜欢的英雄
Jake: 这就是补刀不漏兵吗
Tasha:  是的
Jake: 哈哈哈
Tasha:  一刀不漏呵呵
Katrina:  他的抖音
Katrina:  每天剪他的
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Tasha:  他真的很可爱了
Katrina:  哎对他就每天说
Katrina:  你知道他有多可爱吗
Katrina:  我说谁都给你看
Tasha:  他谁啊好丑啊哈哈
Tasha:  哎这个是国内选手
Lucia: 所以这是个混剪
Lucia: 我以为是他的个人像呢
Tasha:  这个也是国内选手
Alice: 为什么我感觉他又长得有点像那个谁
Tasha:  刘青松
Alice: 不认识是那个
Alice: 王
Tasha:  不知道他已经算是
Tasha:  国内就中国队的第一美男了
Alice: 刚刚那个长得好像那个
Alice: 谁呀
Alice: 想不起来我难受
Tasha:  这些我都不喜欢
Tasha:  都很一般哈哈哈
Jake: 好开点外卖吧
Alice: 王王什么王
Jake: 点点外卖吧
Lucia:  暂存
Tasha:  and我觉得
Alice: 王什么
Alice: 没事王什么来着
Lucia: 没有没有
Tasha:  怎么没了
Alice: 取消了
Jake: 点外卖
Katrina:  一下自己的花纹
Tasha:  这款围很喜欢
Jake: 挑花
Jake: 要不等修硕来
Jake: 我们先把这一端给结了就结束吧
Jake: 上午上午
Alice: 点了是吗
Jake: 就这样还没有点
Alice: 不是啊对啊
Jake: 就是这个
Lucia: 我们好像
Jake: 关掉关掉关掉
Alice: 这就是把这个点掉
Katrina:  还有我们的舞蹈
Tasha:  什么点掉这个
Alice: 就关掉要开始关了是吗对
Tasha:  关掉关掉干嘛好
Jake: 对关掉
Katrina:  哎呀
Alice: 关掉结束了
Tasha:  好吧
Tasha:  我在面对以后的研究人员
Katrina:  天呐感觉货到了那种
Tasha:  我说我们在欣赏电竞美男
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Alice: 那就停了
Lucia: 啊这是你的杯子吗OK OK
Katrina:  我要泡种子
Lucia: complete
Alice:这样ASMR哈哈哈
Tasha: ASMR
Alice:欢迎来到
Alice:星星的
Alice:  呃呃直播化妆空间
Tasha:  喜欢听AMSR吗
Alice:我我每天都要听
Tasha:  你每天都要听我也听
Alice:嗯
Jake:开了吗别别别早了早了
Jake:你已经开了
Tasha: 开了
Alice:我们都开了
Jake:哦这个头发挡住了
Lucia: 没事这很真实
Lucia: 就是我们人类的头发也经常会打碎
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Jake:对对确实确实但是尽量还是
Jake:难度太高他搞不动
Alice:这是歌剧魅影吗
Tasha:  嗯
Alice:好用吗
Alice:好用我也买一个算了我不会遮瑕
Tasha:  我嗯
Tasha:  我的建议是
Alice:我自己来吧
Tasha:  什么你自己来我先
Lucia: 我觉得等我回家
Lucia: 我也得买一个这种大一点的化妆包
Lucia: 我每次东西都放不下
Tasha:  好那我们第一步
Alice:遮瑕
Tasha:  好像没有什么瑕算了
Jake: 第二步
Lucia: 校准一下时间
Jake: 对第二部校准一下
Alice:给他看这个
Tasha:  好这个
Alice:我自己涂开吧嗯
Lucia: 哎我又把我手机撂哪去了
Alice:好
Alice:素人改造计划启动
Tasha:  真的假的
Alice:我一想到这是个摄像头
Alice:我现在有点难受
Alice:有点不好意思
Tasha:  感觉这化妆刷也不是很好用
Tasha:  为什么卖十几块钱一个
Alice:就这样直接粉底得了哎
Alice:我也用了这个UKISS的这个这个底对
Tasha:  打底
Alice:哦我懂了这个叫嗯什么提亮暗沉哦
Tasha:  嗯
Alice:只要手揉开就行了吧啊
Tasha:  啊不不不
Alice:哦这个是拇指
Alice:套是吧
Alice:让外国人研究一下中国的
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: 挺好挺好
Jake: 满分数据我去
Alice:哇其他几个是啥来着
Tasha:  哦你稍微转过来一些
Alice:其他几个是啥来着
Jake: 这是
Lucia: 给你增加一些
Lucia: 人类早期绘制猫咪的珍贵场面
Jake: 哦临摹是吗
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Jake: 现在在
Alice:这 叫面中提亮吗
Alice:是吗
Tasha:  哦
Jake: 我去
Tasha:  是
Alice:我懂但我不会
Jake: 有点专业的
Tasha:  你有点专业在身上呢
Alice:但是我直接就第一步上粉底然后没了
Tasha:  但是我今天也没遮瑕
Alice:我觉得太麻烦了
Tasha:  你的鼻子有一点点塌
Alice:我去度一下吧
Alice:那都不必了
Tasha:  但是我也不知道怎么把他画的很挺
Jake: 好多笔啊
Alice:我会一点点
Jake: 我也在找笔
Tasha:  找什么笔
Jake: 你能写什么笔
Lucia: 哎刚才才那个那支笔
Lucia: 那个咱们用来写那个啥的画
Jake: 是我自己
Jake: 有一只给我扔哪去了
Alice:去哪了
Tasha:  嗯应该是没关系没什么可
Lucia: 不对我把这个爪子画太长了
Alice:可以到粉底了吗
Tasha:  可以了吧
Alice:你这是干皮的还是油皮的
Tasha:  干皮的没事
Alice:无所谓就这样
Alice:你是干皮吗
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha:  完了
Tasha:  感觉我帮你画的不好看
Alice:没关系你不画也不好看
Alice:我自己拍吧
Alice:是不没涂匀
Tasha:  还算匀吧
Jake: 哎呀
Tasha:  鼻翼这再
Tasha: 行
Alice:行
Alice:再涂点
Tasha: 好
Alice:每次都差不多用手把它
Tasha:  我的妈
Lucia: 哈对不起
Lucia: 哈哈
Jake: 呵呵呵
Lucia: 他有那个什么吗
Jake: 这这这
Lucia: 啊啊sorry sorry
Jake: 没事
Lucia: 要命
Lucia: 我今天已经掉了第二次充电宝了
Jake: 没关系劲摔
Tasha:  没关系
Alice:抹脖子
Jake: 抹脖子
Alice:给她抹点
Tasha:  杨老师要来点吗
Jake: 啊
Jake: 我哈哈哈
Jake: 啊抹哪
Lucia: 杨老师化点妆吗
Alice:抹脸上
Lucia: 要哈哈
Lucia: 啊
Jake: 这化妆
Tasha:  眼镜摘下来吧
Lucia: 这个这个充电宝稍微有点大
Jake: 这么专业的
Lucia: 我口袋里放不下
Jake: 要不放椅子上啊
Tasha:  啊粉扑帮您扑开
Lucia: 我可以把他用腿压住
Tasha:  哇
Tasha:  然后说不要动
Tasha:  好美呀好美
Tasha:  不要动不要眨眼睛哈哈
Alice: 我总感觉没弄匀就这样还有点
Tasha:  啊
Tasha:  杨老师你那胡子是不是该刮了
Jake: 嗯确实
Alice:抹匀了吗
Alice:匀了吧
Jake: 匀了吧
Alice:美呀
Lucia: 今天怎么回事
Tasha:  太美了杨老师
Alice: 太美了
Jake: 是啊太美了
Tasha:  太美了
Alice:太美了
Jake: 谢谢
Tasha:  直接白了3个多
Tasha:  您看一看
Jake: 我看一看
Jake: 哈哈哈我去
Jake: 确实
Lucia: 让我看看
Jake: 哈哈
Lucia: 啊太美了
Lucia: 哈哈哈肤质一下就变得特别好
Alice: 哈哈哈
Tasha:  哈哈
Lucia: 不是不是以前也很好
Lucia: 就是更好了
Jake: 这么回事可以
Alice:匀了吧
Tasha:  明了就这吧
Alice:就这吧下一步是睫毛
Jake: 就是这就是什么
Jake: 磨皮吗
Tasha:  睫毛了已经
Alice:啊
Tasha:  腮红吧
Alice:最后再腮红吧
Alice:直接睫毛
Tasha:  啊啊行
Alice:我们是不是用了同款
Alice:v什么d什么安啊
Tasha:  啊
Alice:我用了红色
Alice:好就这样贴
Alice:夹吧我来夹吧
Lucia: 擦了一下之后好像不对称
Tasha:  你要贴假睫毛吗
Alice:贴
Tasha:  好你要用我的吗
Alice:我的假睫毛我不一定会用你
Jake: 我们是不是有买笔这个环节
Alice:这是一条的吗
Jake: 买这个白板笔
Lucia: 白板笔有这个环节吗
Jake: 我怎么记得昨天有这个
Alice:没用过这个
Jake: 没有就算了
Jake: 呵呵没有也可以买
Tasha:  这个免胶
Alice:这个免胶我有胶
Lucia: 打孔器和彩笔
Lucia: 哎确实有
Jake: 哦
Lucia: 但是已经有人在这里打了个勾
Tasha:  我也有叫
Lucia: 我不知道是不是
Tasha:  到底用哪个
Alice:你挑吧
Tasha:  那就免胶的吧
Alice:为什么是免胶呢
Alice:自己带的胶
Tasha:  嗯它上面好像有那种胶吧
Alice:牢固吗
Tasha:  不知道呀
Tasha:  我我都没拆包装呢
Alice:哎呀夹的不太好
Alice:这样吧
Alice:行吗
Tasha:  行
Alice:没夹差不多
Alice:无所谓反正会贴
Alice:嗯等一下睫毛打底
Alice:睫毛打底
Tasha:  哦
Tasha:  它这个胶还可以重复使用
Tasha:  也不知道真的假的
Tasha:  这个粘在最边边
Tasha:  这个粘在中间的那种感觉
Alice:先从中间开始粘
Tasha:  他说不加按夹
Tasha:  曲线夹
Tasha:  取睫毛不要碰到底部的这个胶条
Alice:从中间开始贴吧
Alice:我不知道边边在哪
Tasha:  我也不知道
Alice:来吧
Jake:卧槽
Tasha:  是不是从下面开始加
Tasha:  这样子对
Alice:不能从这不能碰到他
Alice:要不然我们还是用有有胶的吧
Alice:不会用这个
Tasha:  失败
Alice:我有胶
Tasha:  我也有胶
Alice:你用这个用这个吗
Alice:还挺好用的
Tasha:  好好
Alice:给你推荐一下
Alice:我姐姐是化妆师她就给我推荐这个
Tasha:  哦就挤在这啊
Alice:不是有个什么山区哦
Tasha:  哦
Alice:山我没有
Alice:但我刚看到
Alice:一次用3个吗
Tasha:  不知道呀
Tasha:  我就用了一个两个吧
Tasha:  我说我今天没有用过
Alice:这是一个眼型哦
Tasha:  oh
Alice:但颜色有点太长了有点多
Tasha:  有点多
Tasha:  俏
Alice:这也太太太明显了
Alice:太长了
Tasha:  好你要用你的是吗
Alice:用我的吧
Alice:好怕hold不住他
Alice: 我的在哪呢
Alice:我用这个
Tasha:  嗯这不差不多吗
Alice:这个要没那么长
Tasha:  是吗
Tasha:  行
Alice:那用你的吧
Tasha:  啊都可以了
Alice:真的hold不住说实话
Alice:毕竟充满生活地
Tasha:  要找什么
Jake: 笔
Tasha:  我上楼给你拿支笔吧好
Jake: 谢谢
Alice:太长了
Tasha:  哇
Alice:是吧太夸张了
Tasha:  不夸张哈哈
Alice:不夸张这不夸张吗
Alice:我不敢想象这个出现在我的眼上
Alice:不夸张吗
Tasha:  啊
Alice:太夸张了
Tasha:  有点
Alice:把它取下来吧
Alice:用我的那个安回去试一下
Tasha:  还能安回去的是吗
Alice:可以OK
Alice:要不然你贴一个
Alice: 你试一下这个
Tasha:  今天就算了吧
Tasha:  你要不还在这上面粘吧
Alice:也行
Lucia: 嗯这是不好了吗
Tasha:  好果然每个人都有自己适合的
Alice:我i给你也来个
Tasha:  没关系
Tasha:  可以好吧
Tasha:  真的挺自然的
Lucia: 吃草莓吗
Lucia: 姐妹们
Tasha:  哈哈不是作为旁观者
Tasha:  而是开始偷偷洗草莓了开始
Lucia: 对
Lucia: 要吃吗
Alice:谢谢谢谢
Lucia: 我感觉我开始有点饿了
Tasha:  距离我们吃完早饭
Tasha:  可能就一个小时
Lucia: 我也属于饿的比较快那种类型的
Tasha:  嗯你贴到哪了
Alice:没贴哪
Tasha:  哦贴三处是吧
Tasha:  你会贴吗
Lucia: 不会
Lucia: 从来没贴过
Tasha:  吃了
Alice:应该是水珠子
Tasha:  再贴另一个眼睛
Alice:我把胶搁哪
Alice:如果化一半
Alice:饭来了
Alice: 太尴尬了
Lucia: 就民以食为天先吃饭
Tasha: 多挤点我也来贴一个
Lucia: 你以前贴过吗没有
Tasha: 没有
Alice:来吧来吧
Alice:跟我一起
Tasha: 啊不你先贴吧
Alice:我快贴好了
Alice:嗯我贴上了下睫毛快
Tasha: 好吧
Alice:你有下睫毛吗
Tasha: 好
Alice:这是你的下睫毛吗
Tasha: 你要吗你要贴吗
Alice:我没有贴过单块的假睫毛
Tasha: 我都没拆开
Lucia: 果然没贴过
Lucia: 如果饭再不来
Lucia: 我就要开始考虑
Lucia: 偷吃冰箱里昨天的肯德基了哈哈
Tasha: 吃吧吃吧
Lucia: 再等等看
Lucia: 啊真奇怪
Alice:妈呀就这样吧
Alice:好吗
Tasha: 好
Alice:不要管他了
Alice:没什么耐心啊
Alice:逐渐暴躁啊不要他
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: 还好我们几个人都不太会化妆我就安心了
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: 大家都处于同样的这个起跑线上
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice:起跑线是差不多的
Lucia: 你这个帽子好可爱
Lucia: 跟你的衣服颜色特别搭配
Alice:哎呀
Alice:睫毛弄在这上面
Lucia: 可以直接在衣服上擦的吗
Lucia: 那个这里有纸哈哈
Alice:逐渐暴躁
Alice:有的时候就手感运气之类的